hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
testing vaccine's final dose form to usp
787 subvisible particulate matter
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker tony
harrison
senior marketing manager beckman culture
life sciences
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen tony you may
now begin your presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction hello everyone and welcome
to today's
short webinar about 25 minutes on
testing
vaccine final dose form to the united
states pharmacopoeia chapter
787 for subvisible particle matter
now before i start this presentation
today i wanted to share this quote with
you
of course at the moment we are all very
aware of the current
covid pandemic struggle and so i'm sure
we can all resonate with this quote
and hence why i thought today's
presentation was particularly
timely
so as i mentioned today's webinar will
last approximately 25 minutes
and i'll provide a brief overview of why
we test for vaccines for particulate
contamination
compare and contrast the united states
chapters 787
and 788 explain why light
obscuration is the preferred method for
testing for particle contamination
touch on some of the challenges of using
light obscuration counters
for this application and finally explain
how the hayek 9703 plus
particle counter from beckmann coulter
is designed to overcome
these challenges
so first let's take a look at why we
test for particle contamination
there's three primary reasons why we
first focus on particle contamination in
parental products
such as vaccines firstly these products
are delivered
by injection and any particles present
may block veins or capillaries
restricting blood flow which could be
particularly dangerous if they blocked
the capillaries serving the brain
also particles could be carrying
microbes which would form potential
threats in the form of infection
and lastly it is possible that the
foreign body itself could cause an
allergic reaction
maybe even the highly dangerous
anaphylactic shock
in extreme cases
so now let's take a brief look at the
usp 787 and compare it to 788
both of these are designed for
particulate contamination testing in
parenterals
but usp 787 is specifically targeted at
therapeutic proteins
such as vaccines and of course
the manufacturer must specify which usp
tests they're going to release their
product to
and this will of course be captured in
the the product marketing
license so let's take a look at usp
788 first the primary method specified
for carrying out this test in the
pharmacopoeia
is to use a light observation particle
counter
and i'll explain the reason why this
technology is preferred
in a short while now however should the
product
under test not be suitable for light
obscuration testing
then the usp does allow a secondary
method of using
an optical microscope and sizing and
counting the particles by
eye now in order to achieve
a reasonably statistically sound picture
of the contamination levels
in a batch of vaccines the user is
guided to pool
east at least 10 vials from the batch
that's if you're following usp 788
the user is then tasked with extracting
and testing at least
four times five milliliter samples from
the pooled vials
i a total of 20 milliliters and plus the
tear volume of the sample itself
or sampler sorry itself and for this
reason the total pulled volume from the
vials
must be greater than or equal to 25
milliliters
and i'll touch on the tear volume
challenges
in a short while
and for example when files of the final
dose form may only be one milliliter
which is quite common
the user would have to combine not just
10 but a total of 25
vials to achieve the required 25
milliliter pooled volume
now results from the first of the four
samples are discarded
and this is to try to reduce test to
test carryover
and for small volume injectables with a
dose form of less than 100 milliliters
the maximum particle counts per
container is the pass fail criteria so
it's per container
however for larger volume parentals of
greater than 100 milliliter dose form
the pass fail criteria is defined in
terms of counts
per milliliter not counts per container
but in both cases the particle sizes of
interest
are 10 and 25 microns now let's compare
that to usp 787.
now the primary and secondary test
methods defined in 787 are exactly the
same
and the difference starts to come in
where
the number of files are required
due to the typically costly nature of
vaccine products
usp 787 does not mandate the testing of
10 vials per batch
the only rider is that the pooled volume
must be sufficient for the test
and likewise the minimum sample volume
allowed is just
point two of a milliliter instead of
five milliliters
the user will still take four samples
still discard the first sample
but as long as the combined test volume
and counter
tear volume is as small as possible the
test could potentially be done
just using one vial of one milliliter
product
so that's different to 788
like 788 however the particle sizes of
interest are still
10 and 25 microns and the maximum per
container are also the same
however where the product is
greater than 100 milliliters in dose
form the maximum allowable counts per
milliliter and
per container are both pass fail
criteria
do you remember it was just power
particles per container with 788
so provided your product is a protein
based therapeutic
and you can demonstrate compliance to
usp 788
you can save costs and be less wasteful
of the final product
now of course chemically derived small
molecule products
must still be tested to usp 788
787 is just for therapeutic proteins
so i mentioned several times there that
light obscuration is the preferred test
in both
usb 788 and 787
and now i'll explain why that is
the problem was that particles
contaminate our products are very
conveniently spherical in nature
so how do you size them and compare them
between batches when particles are so
irregular in shape and you're counting
them by i which is the
previous method there are several sizing
conventions
but which is correct and on top of that
sizing
by eye using a microscope is a very
subjective process
and what we find is that technicians
that technician differences
in methods creep in and as does human
error
so some way had to be found to
standardize the counting and to allow
the methods chosen
to be validated against certified
traceable materials
now example of the how human heritage
come in with a manual
test here is shown by a study done by
the industrial biodevelopment laboratory
which showed more than 20 percent via
variability sorry in test results
between
15 16 experienced qc technicians all
performing the same
manual standard operating procedure now
clearly the sop
might be able to improved and the
technicians retrained
but such variability and results suggest
that the manual process itself
is not robust enough to deliver the
required levels of quality control
and whilst the technical specifications
of similar particle counting instruments
may appear
equivalent when looking to try to
improve quality control
qc teams should really be looking at the
level of automation in the instrument
which will make the qc testing more
robust and repeatable
now in a light observation counter
there's a light source
typically a laser and which illuminates
through a sampling window in the flow
path
and a detector on the opposite side of
the window
and this detector turns the amount of
light falling on it
into an electrical signal which can be
measured
when particles passing pass through the
measurement window
they partially block the the light
falling onto the sensor
and this reduces the amount of light
falling onto the
detector the change in the detector
electrical output
is proportional to the size of the
particle
flowing through the uh the laser light
now the attraction of this method is
that the counter can be calibrated using
certified traceable calibration beads of
a known size
these beads will obscure a fixed or
certain amount of light
and now any particle however irregular
shaped it is
which obscures the same amount of light
as the calibration beads
can be said to have an equi equivalent
spherical diameter
as the calibration beads thus irregular
shaped contaminating particles may be
sized
according to certified restaurant
reference standards
and no matter what their shape particles
that obscure the same amount of light
will be reported as being the same
equivalent spherical diameter
now this helps almost eliminate the
impact of subjectivity and human error
from the measurement
okay so now you can understand why the
usp
prefers the use of light obscuration
counters for these tests
however there are some challenges of
using this technology
to fully achieve the benefits of testing
to usp
787 so let's take a look at some of
those
now i stated earlier provide the counter
is capable of precision counting in
volumes as
small as 0.2 of a milliliter the whole
test could be done on a vial containing
enough for
enough for four samples plus the tear
volume of the counter
now the tear volume is the volume of the
sample pathway
leading from the vial to the obscuration
counting windows
in many general purpose counters this
tear volume is large enough to prevent
the test
being achieved with just one milliliter
the third challenge with light
observation counters with small volume
samples
is the positioning of the sample probe
inside the vial
under test ideally the sample probe
should be vertical and
central in the vial especially if the
vial is conical
the probe must go down as far into the
vial as possible without touching the
base of the valve
and the probe must not be allowed to get
too close to the surface of the liquid
in the vial
otherwise there's a very real risk of
drawing air into the sample
and of course air bubbles will be
counted as if they were particles
by the light obscuration counter so you
could get a false negative
sorry a false positive there a higher
count than you're expecting
because the count is drawing air so
really holding a probe well
by hand while sampling in a very small
sample
makes it very difficult to avoid these
problems especially if trying to
complete the whole test with just one
milliliter
of product
the second challenge is whether the
counter can achieve
accuracy and precision or repeatability
with sample volumes as small as 0.2
milliliters
so i'm going to use the target here to
explain just what i mean
in the first picture subsequent shots at
the central bullseye
result in hits all over the target and
this can be described as having
neither accuracy nor precision
however in the second position all the
shots are bunched together tightly
but they're not hitting the central
bullseye now this is good precision
but poor accuracy
in the third picture here the shots are
all close to the
bullseye sorry there's one or two
actually hitting it but the shots are
still
scattered and this can be described as
having good accuracy but
poor precision or repeatability
and finally in the last picture this is
what we want where
the shots have all landed in the
bullseye repeatedly demonstrating both
good accuracy and precision
and this is the performance we need from
our light obscuration particle counter
okay coming into the last section of our
talk today
so let's take a look at how the hayek
9703 plus from
beckmanncourt helps users overcome these
challenges
well firstly the hyatt 9703 plus gets
around the tare volume
challenges or problems by having a probe
specifically designed to enable
usp 787 testing which has a tear volume
of just 0.09
milliliters now this should allow the
user for
to perform usp 787 using just
one milliliter of product
secondly the hayak employs a motorized
sampling arm controlled by a precision
stepper motor so it's automated
and this ensures that the probe is
inserted accurately accurately into the
centre of the vial
and as close to the base of the valve
without touching the bottom of the vial
additionally the hayak has a vial clamp
which holds the vial
in place during the test and ensures
that the vial is centralized under the
sampling probe
and this eliminates the variability that
would be introduced should the
technician have to hold the vial
by hand
and thirdly the precision syringe and
stepper motor drive
maintains repeat volume accuracy and
precision on samples as small as 0.2
milliliter which is the smallest
sample volume usp 787 says we can use
and as we can be seen in this table
testing on the sample accuracy of the
high 9703 plus
proves that the accuracy on samples as
small as 0.2 in millimeter is just
plus or minus 1.02 percent
and whereas the precision calculation
gives us a standard deviation of just
0.00205 on these samples
so the counting accuracy itself can be
demonstrated using certified reference
speeds
and you can see here from these test
results that the hayak demonstrates
greater than 90
counting accuracy on samples containing
reference reference speeds
in just a point two milliliter sample
volume
so the hike is suitable for measuring
samples using the smallest sample volume
measured and
measured mentioned so it has permissible
in usp 787
just 0.2 of a milliliter so it requires
four times 0.2 milliliters of sample for
the test plus the tear volume of the
sample probe
which in this case is 0.8 mil
of the sample plus the tear volume tear
volume in the hayak
must be taken into account as i said
which is 0.09 milliliter
and finally you you should aim to leave
some of the sample in the vial once the
test is completed
to ensure that the probe does not pull
air in the finals temple
so say about 0.1 of a milliliter
hence with its automated sample holder
the vial holder
and high accuracy and precision with
just point two milliliter samples
the hayak 9703 can perform usb
787 on vaccine samples with a total
volume of just
one milliliter or slightly under in fact
so that brings me to the end of today's
short presentation on testing
vaccines to usp 787
and thank you very much for watching and
we'll now open the session
up for questions
thank you tony for your informative
presentation
we now have a poll question we'd like to
share with you
it will pop up on your screen now your
participation is
greatly appreciated
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
please explain again what tear volume is
yes certainly i will
so the tear volume is the volume of the
sample pathway that the sample has to
pass through
um on up the sample probe leading to the
light obscuration counting window where
the particles are counted
and in many general purpose counters
this tear volume is quite large
so it prevents the test being achieved
with a small volume of sample
okay thank you tony our next question is
please explain again
what equivalent spherical diameter means
yes certainly that's that's a difficult
one but it's very important really and
it's why
obscuration is used so the particle
counter
is calibrated using certified
calibration beads which
are of course spherical but they're of a
known size
and they obscure a fixed amount of light
in the measurement cell
now subsequently any particle
that enters the the measurement cell
doesn't matter what shape they are
if they obscure the same amount of light
as the calibration beads
they can be said to have an equivalent
spherical diameter
and this means that we can counter
regular shaped contaminating particles
and size them according to certified
reference standards which gives us the
traceability
and no matter what their shape the
particles that obscure
the same amount of light will be
reported as having the same
equivalent spherical diameter and of
course the main impact here is it helps
to reduce
uh the impact of subjectivity and human
error on these measurements
okay great thank you and our last
question is
why do you say that holding a vial by
hand when testing is not practical
yeah so ideally i mean most most
particle counters you especially
particularly with a single vial
attempting to hold it by hand but
ideally the sample probe
on a very small volume it should be
vertical and central in the vial
and especially if the vial bottom is or
the base is conical
and the probe must go down as far into
the valve as possible without touching
the base
of the vial and the probe itself must
not be allowed to get too close to the
surface of the liquid during sampling
and remember there's four samples to be
drawn otherwise there's a risk of
drawing air in with the samples
if you get air in the sample it's
counted as bubbles
sorry counted as particles and that will
um
skew your test results so holding the
pro
uh the vial by hand while the sample is
tested makes it very difficult to avoid
these problems
especially if you're trying to complete
the whole test with just
a one milliliter of product
thank you tony do you have any final
comments for our audience
no um thank you very much indeed for
your time and thanks for watching
everybody and i think we're all just
praying for the arrival of the covid
vaccine so
that's why i thought this was topical
today
yes thank you again tony for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor beckmann culture life
sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye